Hmm.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Yes,
that's right.
Today the focus channel has reached
50,000
subscribers.
This is a big day for me.
When I started my channel,
I always had the dream in mind,
the goal in mind of reaching 50,000
subscribers,
and I thought that was kind of the
pinnacle.
Now it seems like that's an achievable
goal and we'll see how much further I
can get them $50,000,
but for now I've achieved my initial
goal and that's really great.
Really exciting for me.
So thank you for all of your support.
So onto today's topic imagined that
there was a mysterious language in
Europe that was surrounded on all sides
by languages that it had absolutely no
connection with wealth.
Directionally is a language like that.
The language is the Basque language.
Basque is a language isolate,
meaning that it has no known connection
to any other language.
It's located in Europe,
but it's not an Indo European language.
It forms its own language.
Family ended is quite distinct,
very different from Indo European
languages.
It is spoken by the basket people in the
Basque country or region that spans the
Spain,
France border in the Western most
Pyrenees mountains.
It is not spoken by all Basques,
but by around 27 percent of them in the
basket country.
Overall,
the number of native speakers is
714,000,
135 out of a total population of 2
million,
648,998,
and that includes about 663,000
on the Spanish side and 51,100
on the French side.
It is an official language at the
regional level in Spain,
in the basket,
autonomous community and in I've already
in France,
it holds no official status.
The origins of the Basque language are
shrouded in mystery.
As I said before,
it is a language isolate.
It is thought to be the last remaining
language that existed in Europe before
the arrival of the Indo European
languages.
There is conclusive evidence that basket
is a descendant of the aqua tanium
language,
which is an ancient language spoken in
the Pyrenees region.
Some similarities are known between
Aquitania and the ancient Iberian
language,
so some people think that they might be
related,
but those similarities might just be due
to geographic proximity and mutual
influence.
We don't know.
Some linguists suggests that Aqua Tinian
was part of a wider language family
called the vest chronic languages which
covered most of Europe before the
arrival of the Indo European languages,
but again,
we don't know other people draw
connection between baskin,
other non into European languages like
the Caucasian languages,
but again,
that's right.
We don't know.
One thing we do know is that the Basque
people who descend mostly from farmers
who arrived in the area around 6,000
years ago were isolated from the outside
world for thousands of years.
That's probably partly of the best
countries,
forested mountain terrain and it's lack
of tempting resources that prevented
invasion.
This isolation is probably what allowed
their language to survive and develop
into the Basque language of today.
Of course,
there were Latin borrowings into the
language and there have been other
romance language borrowings throughout
the centuries,
but nothing like the total disappearance
of other pre Latin languages in that
area.
Basketball's a unified language until
the Middle Ages,
when it began to diverge into dialects
because of administrative and political
divisions within the Basque country,
despite being ruled by outside regimes
throughout the centuries,
the best country still remained isolated
and relatively uninfluenced by the
outside world,
and that includes the language.
But when Francisco Franco became ruler
of Spain in 1939,
the use of Basque was heavily suppressed
because Franco wanted to assimilate all
of Spain into castilian culture.
It was forbidden to speak baskin schools
and to public.
It was banned from media and removed
from public services.
This led to a big reduction in the
number of people who could speak the
Basque language,
and that's part of the reason that only
27 percent of people in the Basque
country speak the language.
Today.
In the 19 sixties that suppression was
eased somewhat and Basque language
schools became permitted and the
language begin being used in
publications and in education.
Again,
this led to the creation of a
standardized language called [inaudible]
about [inaudible].
It was developed by the Basque Language
Academy or the Scouts and the uh,
and it was intended to be comprehensible
to speakers of the various dialects of
basket.
There are five main basket dialects be
Skyann or western basket,
keep Fusco on or central Basque.
Upper Novari's,
Novari's,
Freudian,
and the town in France.
These dialects correspond with the
historic provinces of the Basque
country,
but they don't completely correspond
with the modern provinces of today.
The level of intelligibility depends on
the distance between those two dialects
on the dialect continuum with the most
distant dialects,
having trouble understanding each other,
but that's where the standard language
use got about two or comes in.
So what is the Basque language like?
Well,
it's vocabulary has been influenced by
the surrounding romance languages to
some extent,
but when you look at it structure,
you will see that it is unlike any
romance language or like any Indo
European language for that matter,
bass,
Kaz grammatical cases,
12 cases to be exact,
but that is not really unusual in Indo
European languages,
but it has something called the
[inaudible] case.
That means that there's a special form
of the noun when it's the subject of a
sentence and it takes a transitive verb.
That means it has a direct object.
This ergotism case is marked with a k at
the end of the known.
Now,
along with the [inaudible] case,
there is also something called the
absolute of case.
This is for subjects of intransitive
verbs,
meaning that it has no direct object,
and in this case there was no ending on
the end of the.
Now,
well,
let's take a look at a couple of
sentences.
Who America?
Leanne,
that means the child fell in the street.
But if we look at it word by word,
you can see the interesting structure of
Basque word by word.
It's child the street.
The in fall is if we look at the first
word there,
who may his child,
but then the definite article is the a
at the end.
Then for the next word,
Kellyanne Conway is street and then the
definite article is up and then in the
end,
at the end of the word,
if we look at the next word,
God,
that's a verb,
meaning fall,
but it's in the perfect aspect.
That means that it shows a completed
action and then the auxiliary verb comes
after the main verb at the end and this
one means is it's the present tense form
of to be.
And another sentence,
Maddie,
that means the man has given the book to
the child,
so word by word man,
the [inaudible] case child,
the data of case book,
the given has.
The first word is Gisele knuck.
The zone is man than the definite
article is a and then the negative case
is k Lumiata.
That's child again,
child is meant and then this time it has
the definite article a and then it has
the date of case marker.
The at the end,
the date of case basically shows who or
what is being affected by the action,
the next word,
the Buddha,
the Buddha to his book,
and then as the definite article,
and this one looks like a lone word from
a romance language.
The next one a month is a verb and it's
in the perfect aspect showing that the
action is completed and then the
auxiliary verb deal comes after and that
means has and the next sentence in my
view,
that means the woman has seen the memo,
so word by word woman the or gets IV
case man is a scene has.
So the first word in Morocco may act in
macrame is woman.
That is the A and ergonomic cases.
TheK ,
the next word [inaudible].
That's the man and the definite article.
Again,
the next word is [inaudible],
which means scene and again,
that's a verb with the perfect aspect,
showing the actions completed and then
the auxiliary verb comes at the end and
it means has,
as you can see,
the Basque language is very different
from any Indo European language.
Very different from any language that
I've studied,
but it also looks quite logical and
systematic.
It would be a shame to lose a language
that's so unique and that connects us
with the ancient history of Europe.
The number of Basque speakers has
sharply declined over the last century,
but there are efforts in Spain to revive
the language and to make it more
widespread again and hopefully such
efforts will continue and become more
prominent in France as well.
Thank you for watching the length focus
channel.
I want to say thanks again to all of my
patreon supporters.
You guys are awesome.
I appreciate you.
Thanks to all those other people who
volunteered in different ways by
creating subtitles for videos or
offering to write some scripts for Geo
focused or all of those things.
Also be sure to check out the line focus
facebook account,
a twitter account and instagram because
I'm often on there and that's a way to
keep in touch and always know when I
have new content being released.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.